♫I don't think you know, what you think you know baby♫
♫but baby don't you think that I know what I know maybe♫
♫Baby I know, what you think that I don't know♫
♫I know, I know, I know, I know, I know
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know♫
♫I know that you don't think I know that I know what I know♫
♫I don't know what you think I think, think you know I don't♫
♫But I know what you don't think I know, I know, I know, I know♫
♫Baby I know that you don't know what I know♫
♫I don't know what I think but I know what I know♫
♫But you think that you know what I know that you don't♫
♫That I know what you think I don't know♫
♫I know, I know, I know, I know, I know♫
♫I know that you don't think I think that I know what I know♫
♫I don't know what you think I think, think you know I don't♫
♫But I know what you don't think I know, I know, I know, I know♫
♫Baby I know that you don't know what I know♫
That song only has ten words in it
And yes...
I have been struck down by the evil goddess Influenza
Do you remember the tiny chicken?
If you remember the tiny chicken,
well you've been with us for a long time.
The tiny chicken has returned,
and it's laying its little, tiny chicken eggs in my brain.
And their liquid is coming out of my nose
Tiny chicken
I wrote that 10 word song as part of the Masters of Song Foo song writing challenge
and I'm submitting it today and it will be up with a bunch of other 10 word songs,
at quickstopentertainment.com on Thursday.
If you want to check those out.
I did want you all to know one thing though,
like there are some amazing ventriloquists in the world,
but none of them can do this...
-Hank starts singing a single note-
-Puppet sings harmony-
I'm not actually a ventriloquist
Also I wanted to mention that there is something very sort of strange and cool and amazing going on,
with this thing that I have been following called thisisnottom.com
thisisnottom.com was a bunch of really cool riddles,
but the riddles and the challenges are very rewarding when you get them
and it seems to be taking a turn for the awesome, so...
Uh, thisisnottom.com if you are interested in uh ways to while away the time,
while being entertained and also uh,
fascinated.
So if you want hours of amusement, banging your head against you desk and then saying,
"Ahhhh"
I don't suggest doing it while on NyQuil, uh that makes things more difficult.
I have to go to sleep,
and do my taxes.
I don't know if I can do both those things at the same time,
but I'm gonna try.